Yeah, so so in that article we quoted
ourselves from a while back when we were
saying that um
we believe that
quantum computers capable of cracking
elliptic curve cryptography, the ones
the one used in most blockchains,
is
at least decades away if it will ever
materialize.
Um having said that,
uh
we
talked about how our architecture is
actually well prepared for
implementing alternative signing
methods. So, we have already
demonstrated
um that
we will support quantum-resistant
accounts
by mainnet launch. I am
I have been working on supporting them
more natively
so that we get even more efficiency
doing it.
But, um
so now a couple of some news dropped
where
there have been some theoretical
optimizations in how you could solve
uh or implement Shor's algorithm, which
is
the trick to
cracking crypto keys or finding really
large prime numbers.
And in with much fewer qubits than was
previously thought. So,
that
brought the solution an order of
magnitude or so closer.
And another evolution is that using
uh so-called neutral atoms, um
the chances of being able to actually
run
uh tens of thousands of qubits
uh
in a realistic uh machine
have increased.
So, I think in the very most optimistic
um
predictions
more or less
um
in the mid 2030s, you might see
quantum computers
that could possibly attack um say a
single
blockchain key pair
um
in
running in a few days, like or maybe 10
days, running at full bore. Now, that
wouldn't be
sensible to do unless that account has
at least
like $100,000 worth of crypto in it or
more.
um
Probably a lot more. And uh also
wouldn't really be sensible
un-
unless there weren't any other
attractive business cases for
that kind of quantum computer. But, it
turns out there are. There are
interesting computing business cases
like protein folding
uh simulations and uh
and all kinds of stuff that would be
really, really interesting to run on
those machines.
So,
we think that our analysis holds up
really well.
um
You would keep
most of your funds, if you even have
funds uh of that size, you would you
could have one uh
or a couple of safe accounts
that are protected by quantum resistant
uh signatures.
And then, you can keep using
elliptic curve crypto
um
for the lower value accounts. And